[موسيقى]
لطالما وصفت باريس بانها مدينه الانوار
لجمال اضوائها لكن هذه المدينه الساحره
التي ياتي اليها السياح من كل حد وصوب
تخفي وجه الاخر مظلما لا يعرف سوى من عاش
فيها وتجول في شوارعها
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاحياء المهمشه يعيش الكثير من
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين الذين لا يملكون
اوراق ثبوتيه تخولهم للعمل بشكل نظامي في
فرنسا لماذا يلجئون للعمل بالاسود وهنا
يصبح هؤلاء اسرع في عالم شبه منزل لا
تحيطه حمايه ولا يظبطه قانون
[موسيقى]
فوزي مهاجر غير شرعي من الجزائر قدم الى
فرنسا هو وعائلته بحثا عن ظروفا افضل لكنه
فوجئ هنا بما كان بعيدا عن توقعاته فبعد
ان بدا رحله البحث عن وظيفه لم يكن امامه
سوى طريق العمل بالاسود اشتغل لمده عامين
كعامل توصيل في احدى شركات توزيع المواد
الغذائيه عانى كثيرا من سوء المعامله
والاستغلال ومقابل اجرا زهيدا كان يعمل
حوالات 90 ساعه في الاسبوع متجاوزا بذلك
لحد القانوني وهو خمس وثلاثون ساعه
انا كنت اشتغل في شركه احنا خمسه اثنين
بدون اوراق
كل الشغل علي انا روح حمل اولا ثانيه
صباحا ثانيه صباح لكم لازم تكوني في
المستودع دنيا
15 يوم وحدي وفي شغالين اخرين ثلاثه
يستغلوا هذا المنطقه هذا تاع الانسان
[موسيقى]
يكاد يرتبط مفهوم العمل بالاسود بمنطق
الاستغلال من الصعب جدا ايجاد شخصا لديه
عمل غير مصرح به ولا يشكو من معاناه سواء
لناحيه زياده عدد الساعات او نقص في الاجر
او المعامله بعنصريه
باريس ومحيطها هناك 22 في المئه
من المهاجرين وهي نسبه عاليه جدا
عندما نقارنها مع المناطق الفرنسيه الاخرى
التي لديها نحو اربعه في المئه فقط من
العمال المهاجرين وغالبا ما يشغلون كما هو
الحاله هنا مهنا متواضعه مقارنه ببقيه
المهن الاخرى في نسبه عاليه منهم يعملون
في المساعده المنزليه والطبخ واعمال
البناء والحراسه وفي هذه الوظائف في غالبا
ما تكون ساعات العمل متقطعه ويعمل فيها
المهاجرون باعداد اكبر من غير عمل المحدده
[موسيقى]
ساعات الدوام ويمنع ان يعمل الموظف اكثر
من 48 ساعه في الاسبوع لكن في حاله العمل
بالاسود يختلف الوضع كليا وصاحب العمل هو
من يفرض ساعاته بدون قيود متجاهلا بذلك
حجم الجهد وقدره الشخص على التحمل
العمل لفتره طويله يمكن ان يضر بصحه العمل
وفقا لدراسه اجرتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
نشرت في 2021 فالعمل اكثر من 55 ساعه في
الاسبوع يزيد من خطر الوفاه الناجمه عن
امراض القلب والسكته الدماغيه
[موسيقى]
عيون احسن من البشر
يعني
مع السلامه
وانت عندك عائله عندك اولاد 99% راني
ندمانه
[موسيقى]
لم يقتصر بحثنا على المناطق التي يكثر
فيها تواجد المهاجرين بل ذهبنا الى ابعد
منها حتى وصلنا الى جده
الشارع الاكثر شهره في فرنسا حيث توحي
مظاهر الترف هنا انا لا مكان لتلك
الانتهاكات هل العمل بالاسود منتشر باحياء
معينه في باريس مثلا الاحياء الشعبيه
هو موجود بالحياه الشعبيه وبالحياه الراقي
بنفس الوقت هلا نحن
في محل هون مطعم ومالها اشتغلت فيه لمده
شهر بالاسود وبنفس الوقت في عندك في منطقه
الشاذليان هي باريس سان جيرمان يعني هي
باريس 16 كمان بنفس الوقت فيها مطاعم كثير
وفيها شغل بالاسود الشغل بالاسود موجود
بكل مكان فيه مطاعم مباراه الاهلي يعني
موجود كل الاحياء بفرنسا
[موسيقى]
يلاحق المهاجرين في اماكن عملهم لا يفرق
كثيرا بين من لديه اوراق او لا فهذا الشاب
لاجئ سوري لم يحميه وضعه النظامي في البلد
من الوقوع في فخ بعض المحتالين
عرض عليه انه يشتغل هذا المحل بعد اول شهر
قال لي انه مرضت فتره انه يسافر اعطاني
مفتاح البيت من فضيحه المطعم سيارته لحتى
يكون في بيناتنا الثقه اساس بعد ثلاثه
اشهر رجع هو شخص من السفر على اساس انه
صارت بخير
صاحب المطعم استغل جهل شاب قوانين العمل
وجعله يوقع على عقد وهمي ولان الاثباتات
لم تكن كافيه للمحكمه علقت القضيه دون حكم
على رب العمل
[موسيقى]
طريق العمل غير النظامي محذوفه بالمخاطر
ليس فقط بالنسبه للعمال بالنسبه لاصحاب
الاعمال الذين يتهربون من دفع مستحقات
الموظف للضمان الاجتماعي والسلطات
الضريبيه هذا الفعل يضعهم تحت مسائله
القانونيه في حال كشف امرهم وفي لقائنا مع
ميسر ابو غليون وهو استشاري عمالي من
الذين يدافعون عن الموظفين في المحاكم
العماليه تعرفنا على نص القانون وما يترتب
على اكل الطرفين
جدا
تعتبر انه المال العام ضرائب مقدسه لذلك
المشرع
سجن ثلاث سنوات زائد مخالفه 45 الف يورو
يعني كل عامل يعني
غير مصرح
والعقوبه يعني تقريبا بدوبل للخمس سنوات
سجن مع 75000 يورو مخالفه اذا وجدوا عامل
تحت 18 سنه
وحتى تذهب
العقوبه الى التجاره للبشر
بالنسبه للمهاجرين غير الشرعيه الذين لا
يملكون اوراق في فرنسا وبالنسبه للاجئين
ما هي
العواق
المحققين الذين يذهبون هدوم المحققين
ضرائب ليس دورهم تسليم هذا الرجل
اذا مقيم وعم تشتغل بالاسود هو المشكله
عندك
يعني بدك تعوض مركز المساعدات الدولي كل
شيء
والضرائب ستقوم بمراجعه حساباتك 3 سنوات
الى الوراء
وتعوضهم وتستطيع المساعدات الاجتماعيه
ان ترفع دعوه ضدك امام المحاكم وفيها
سنتين سجن مع 375 الف يورو مخالفه لانك
انت تسرق اموال الدوليه
[موسيقى]
مليونان ونصف المليون عدد العاملين
بالاسود في فرنسا معظمهم من المهاجرين غير
الشرعيه او اللاجئين الذين فقدوا الامل في
الحصول على وظائف نظاميه ورغم ان الدوله
تحارب هذا النوع من الاعمال لكن نسبه
كبيره من المهاجرين تنخرط فيها نظرا
للعوائق الكبيره التي تواجههم من اجل
الحصول على عمل نظامي
في البرلمان الفرنسي على الجهود التي
تبذلها السلطات للكشف عن حالات العمل غير
المصرح به
الاسود هو بالتاكيد غير قانوني
دون تصريح
به وايضا صاحب العمل او الشركه التي لديها
موظف بالاسود نحن بالطبع في حاجه الى مزيد
من عمليه التفتيش وتحتاج ايضا الى التاكد
من العقوبات راضعه
[موسيقى]
الانتقادات كثيره المعارضه غير راضي عن
اداء الحكومه في مكافحه العمل بالاسود
خاصه مع استمرار ازمه المهاجرين غير
الشرعيه
وسياسه الحكومه في غض البصر عن بعض
الحالات سمحت بازدهار العملي غير القانوني
حتى انها تشجع عمل منصات الانترنت التي
اصبحت بعضها معروفه بوجود العمال الاجانب
غير الشرعيين فيها نحن لا نريدهم على قيد
الحياه فقط بل نريدهم ان يعملوا ويعيشوا
حياه كريمه لذا يمكننا بدر المزيد من
الجهود وبشكل افضل
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا تتزايد الحاجه الى اليد العامله
بشكل كبير فهناك نقص الحديد في الكثير من
المهن الخدميه والحكومه اليوم تسعى الى سد
هذه الثغره من خلال سني قوانين جديده بهدف
تسويه اوضاع بعض المهاجرين غير الشرعيه
على اراضيها للاستفاده من وجودهم وايجاد
حلولا لتوظيفهم بشكل النظامي
في الدوله الفرنسيه وضعت خطا يوجد هناك من
انواع من الاعمال العمل في البناء العمل
في المطاعم في الفنادق في التنظيف في
مساعده
كبار السن في البيوت الممرضات
والحتى السائقين الكميونات والباصات ان كل
من قم بهذا العمل
يذهب الى البروجكتير منطقه الشرطه ويقوم
ويقول انا اعمل وعندي عقد عمل
فسوف يعطونه الاقامه وهذه المبادره جيده
من الحكومه التي تتخبط
[موسيقى]
ها وزاره العمل ان غالبيه العمال
المهاجرين تشغل وظائف شاقه في فرنسا اذا
يتعرضوا هؤلاء لضغوط كبيره في قطاع العمل
تقدرهم الى خوض غمار مهن صعبه تشهد عاده
نقصا في العيد العامله
انا كنت نخدم ديميناجمون
عام ونص وانا نخدم ديميناجمو بدون اوراق
معليش انا مستعد قدامك انا اديني نخدم وين
تحب وين تحب نخدم لك اخدم لك في الروقار
ندخل نخدم فيه عادي
ما عندي حتى نخدم ايسونسيال نجيب القوط
تاعي
[موسيقى]
وكل ما زادت صعوبه الظروف العمل زاد
احتمال ان يحصل المهاجر على وظيفه في
فرنسا وظيفه واحده من اصل عشر وظائف
يشغلها عامل من اصول اجنبيه
في الصباح وايضا في فتره ما بعد الظهر
ويتطلب الوجود في اماكن مختلفه احيانا
والمهاجرون في بدايه وصولهم الى هنا
يقبلون احيانا بهذه الوظائف على عكس
الاشخاص الاخرين الذين استقروا منذ فتره
اطول والذين لديهم مستويات من التعليم
وبالتالي ايضا حظوظهم في التوظيف ليست
نفسها
[موسيقى]
واقع صعب يقود الكثير منهم الى استخدامه
هويات مزيفه للحصول على عمل النظام وهو
امر اصبح شائعا ففي معظم الحالات يستعير
مهاجرون من دون اوراق معلومات واسماء
معارفهم الذين يتمتعون بوضع قانونيتمكن من
العمل
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
انت ليست تخبري في كتير
كتير كتير
اذ يعمل بتوصيل الطلبات نحو 2500 مهاجرا
من دون وثائق فقد سجل جميعهم عبر موقع
الشركه حسابات باستخدامه هويات مزيفه
ليتمكن من العمل لكن المؤسسه طردتهم هذا
العام بحجه انها اكتشفت وضعهم غير النظامي
بعد حوالي ثلاثه اعوام من العمل معها خلال
الرائحه كورونا وعلى اثر القرار يتظاهر
المئات منهم اسبوعيا في باريس للمطالبه
بتسويه اوضاعهم
نحن في وضع غير النظامي
لانه ليس لدينا خيار ليس امامنا سوا هذا
العمل واذا لم نفعل ذلك كيف سنعيش كيف
سندفع ايجار السكن
العامل بدون اوراق له حقوق الا يخاف
يستطيع ان يذهب حتى الى المحاكم الفرنسيه
للدفاع عن حقوقه اييي اذا رب العمل
يعني طرده
اذا ذهب الى المحكمه
اللي هي محاكم خاصه بحقد العمل ما بين
العامل ورب العمل
يستطيع اذا اثبته انه كان يعمل وترضه لرب
العمل ان ياخذ سته اشهر
تعويض لانه طرد
ويستطيع ان يجبر رب العمل في المحكمه ان
يعيد همم اعمال له عقد ويدفع له كل
الضرائب يعني مو لانه ما معنى اوراق يعني
ليس لنا حقوق
[موسيقى]
التحرش الجنسي ظاهره منتشره في اوساط
العمل بالاسود لكنها تبقى من التابوهات
المغلقه والنساء اللواتي لا يملكن اوراق
اقامه هنا اكثر عرضه لتلك الانتهاكات حيث
يجد صاحب العمل نفسه امام فريسته سهله
مجرده من الحقوق فيجرى على التمادي عليها
بالقول او الفعل
[موسيقى]
هذا ما جرى مع هذه السيده وهي مهاجره غير
شرعيه من اصول عربيه تعيش مع عائلتها في
باريس تعرضت للاستغلال والتحرش من قبل
صاحب مطعم كانت تعمل لديه تجربه مريره
عاشتها سلمى وهي في الثامنه عشر من عمرها
عندما سلكت اول مره طريق العمل غير المرخص
به والتي دفعتها في النهايه الى التفكير
بانهاء حياتي
[موسيقى]
بعد كم يوم صار يسال اسئله محرجه
بعدين صار يحكي كلام يعني غير مباشر كنت
اعمل حالي مش فاهماني بالمره بطنش بس بعد
فتره صار كلام مباشر
صار يقل الادب كثير وصار يعني يعني يعرض
مبالغ يعني اليوم يعرض مبلغ وبكره بيزيد
عليه وبعده بزيد عليه قلت له انا مستحيل
انا جاي اشتغل ما بدي
مستحيل راح اسوي
بالشغل مثلا
فتره يعني صرت لما اجي افوت على الشغل
ببكي لما اطلع نفس الشيء
يعني لما وصلت معي لمرحله انه
حاولت انتحر
طلعت من الشغل
ولم تستطع سلمى اخفاء دموعها امامنا فما
خلفته هذه التجربه من شعور سيء ما زال
محفورا في ذاكرتها
[موسيقى]
تتشابه القصص الى حد كبير جاد ايضا كان
شاهدا في مكان عمله على محاوله تحرش حصلت
امام عينيك
وصاحب المحل كثير الاسود
[موسيقى]
وتقول لي انا بحاجه بسيطه
تشتغل بالاسود فكان كثير هذا الموضوع
قدامي كثير مزعج يعني كان انسان يطلع عنه
ممكن هالمره تكون امه واخته اي حدا والبنت
اضطرت توقف عمل لانه هي ما بدها تقدم له
شيء لهذا الشهر العمر هو وعد انه اذا
بتساوي كل شيء معه بيعطيها عقد عمل بساعده
بالسكن بيساوي لكل شيء بس هو كذاب من
البدايه هو بس بده غلط معين
[موسيقى]
مهما كان الظروفها لكنها اكثرهن لا يعلمن
بذلك
ليس عندها اوراق انها تعرضت للتحرش الجنسي
اذا كان تحرش جنسي قويه تستطيع ان تاخذ
اوراقها من وراء ذلك الامور
سوق العمل مليء بقصص الانتهاكات عبوديه
مخفيه في مكان ظاهره الحداثه وباطنه لا
يختلف كثيرا عن ما هو حاصل في بقيه اصقاع
الارض
[موسيقى]